what happened with um because
because e40 kind of brought you into the
game and and i know
you know shout out to our boy ken who's
still you know with you
um what uh what happened where you're no
longer with
sick with it like i'm trying to like i'm
trying to branch out
man i'm really trying to be like mogul
status you know
you're trying to get on some e40s
no i'm saying so i feel like and i feel
like he won't do what he wanted me to do
your family i feel like
no i'm saying we all trying to be bosses
at the end of the day you know
it's all respecting [ __ ] from us all a
little bit at the end of the day they're
business
what um what did you learn from 40
i learned a whole lot before i was just
talking about [ __ ] i learned before the
last night for him like
some [ __ ] that just came with my mind
out of the blue
but he really taught [ __ ] like
longevity is
really the most important thing
in the game like if you're in longevity
because it'd be so many waves they'd be
like coming and going coming and going
coming and going once you find you and
you can have a packet
in any way if you feel good
yeah i think that like you would rather
kind of have a 20-year career
that's like consistent then like a crazy
two years
you feel what i'm saying and then you're
just like who did what happened to this
[ __ ] guy
you gonna learn how to you're gonna
learn how to manage the money and
everything like
the whole 20 years yeah and then you'll
always have your catalog
you'll be able to do your shows
you might be cool for three years after
that scrolling two years and then